[Musik]
herzliche gastfreundlichkeit und heute
wird es richtig geisteskrank aber
richtig geisteskrank zwei worte leute
lamborghini
[Musik]
[Applaus]
peg
[Musik]
noch fragen der geisterzug und der geld
es geht wieder alles bestens die erst
heute hergekommen nach köln fiel vielen
dank wir sehen die kölner dom im
hintergrund ganz kurz sofort am anfang
der hintergrund ihr seht junger typ
wie läuft das erst du hast modelabel
loleit seht ihr einmal hier
los und auch geil hier
düsseldorf 11 loleit 650 x der wagen 650
ps leute ich habe vier liter v8 ihrer
2,2 tonnen und das ist meiner meinung
nach bisher 20 den haag angefahren aber
ich finde das ist der geilste lambo
meiner meinung nach meiner meinung nach
auch egal das passt einfach weg wir
kommen hier kann man ja ihr wisst ja
leute auf dem lambro warten wir mal nah
dran geht seht ihr das ist ein stier und
lambert ganz oft immer stiere als
namensgeber für die auto zb der gallardo
das war seine kampfstier asse wo es hier
kommt von dem wort für den auerochsen
dass eine ausgestorbene russell
wurde ich auch uhr genannt und aus uran
urus kraft der gast zu krank alters
sogar ich sag euch warum ich hab es zu
richtig geil finde lambo stehe auf dem
wappen und das ist einfach so ein fetter
vetter klotz windstill und tetta klotz
so ferrari hat ein pferd drauf das
cavallino okay bis ein bisschen kleiner
schmaler und das hier ist einfach
einfach ein richtig hätte kiste ist
natürlich leihmutter zum
volkswagen-konzern auf der modularen
längsbaukasten
ja längst heißt der teilt sich die
plattform mit dem band tiger mit dem
erst acht auch da ist auch ein sehr
ähnlicher motorrad hier mehr leistung
650 ps 850 meter egal ist einfach kranke
kiste übrigens leute noch ein krasses
detail das ist der erste song der in
serie mit dem turbo gebaut wurde ach ja
das dii haben sonst nur saugen im
programm und richtig krass auf die erste
suv der in großserie gebaut wurde gab
vor einer ganz langen zeit mal den lm
grieche abgesperrte kiste suv mit v12
sauger damals er war ein flop ja der
ging nicht sagt statt dem 300 stück
verkauft oder sowas nicht schlecht ja
das ging nicht aber hier urus
eingeschlagen wie eine bombe ihr wisst
ja leute suv wahnsinn ist aktuell und
die haben glaube ich 218 im ersten jahr
wo der ur so wichtig auf dem markt war
schon 40 prozent aller modelle als uhr
ausverkauft kraft ja richtig krass kommt
er mir hinten drauf ihr könnt das nicht
so gut lesen was im kopf ist aber mir
325 eher schlappen hintendrauf vorne 285
hallo
23 zoll carbon keramik bremsen passend
zum italiener auch wieder mit pizza
blechinger war das für eine bremsscheibe
kummer ist geisteskrank schon also wenn
das 23 zoll felgen sind dann ist das
eine 18 zoll bremsscheibe oder so haben
halt mal dorthin haben manche leute
nicht als felgen auf dem auto so rega
ist zu krank waren 3,6 sekunden null auf
hundert macht der und er ist einfach
immer direkt mit rein die machen ihr
kurzem prozess das ist halt das geile
wenn man ein italiener hat der quasi
deutsche brüder hat weil dann ist der
innenraum so was von schock alter das
hat der jetlag deswegen jetzt lambo
style hier das ist für
rhythmus hier ist wahrscheinlich und
hier ist dieser der anima schalter anima
ist italienisch für für seele da kommt
ja ja da kann man umschalten zwischen
strahler straße sport corsa sabia ist
santhera ist erde und nevis schnee dann
hast hier drüben wenn ihr mal reinschaut
das kann ich mir nur so erklären dass
muster differenzialsperre seien hier
dämpfer lenkung oder vielleicht auch
farbig einstellung das war
wahrscheinlich einer differenzialsperre
stehen hebel recht haben schon den juni
heißt einfach ego hebel
geile schön kompakte schaltwippen hier
kann man hier um die ecke denken olufsen
der egal wenn wir an machst dann fahren
die raus echt sexy ja so kommen leute
jetzt start
das geil ja wir haben uns über das geil
und langsam wirklich sehr sehr geil
details sind die detail bei lamborghini
fast noch geiler als bei ferrari also
hier zum beispiel die die italienischen
farben hier im lenkrad die haben wir
auch außen hier vorne wollte schon mal
rote flagge
dass wir auch gerade daher genau war
erst das marokkanische wurzeln
und wir wirklich also ja ihr seht videos
aber ihr als richtig korrekter typ feier
des todes eingestellt einfach geil guck
mal die combinos diese uhr
[Gelächter]
okay aber noch hilfreich schon haben wir
auch ganz gut platz ich kann jetzt nach
vorne locker sitzen baba ist schon gut
platz es gibt denen als viersitzer ja
ich hab den arbeitsmarkt dann muss das
auch klappt mit der gamer ja das ist
klar du hast nämlich auch hot chip
gemacht wir haben ein paar gemeinsame
freunde mit denen war es in deutschland
unterwegs habe ich auch in münchen wir
sind von düsseldorf nach köln frankfurt
damit den dave zum flughafen gebracht
wir weiter nach münchen danach stuttgart
wieder zurück und dann war sie also über
hat somit sozial weil feiern und so was
wie ein bisschen wir haben bisschen chip
gemacht wie geil der gala für die leute
gar nicht lange auf die folter spannen
wissen vielleicht einmal kurz staaten
für soundcheck soundtrack und dann
fahren wir den
west.de egal
[Musik]
träger ist das krank
damit würde ich sagen kriegen wir direkt
rein
fahren muss und damit setzen wir drin
leute im lamborghini urus
geist des kranken am fahren wir wenn ich
heute den ganz schlau gemacht 2000 die
kuh und haben uns eine unbegrenzte
autobahnen rausgesucht auf der route
gute darf während anfang märz erkennen
erste frage in diesem format immer was
bedeuten autos aber ich sage dir ganz
ehrlich das ist schon so ein bisschen
spielzeug zu sein damals einfach wie
früher waren klein war es so und jetzt
ist keine ahnung ist einfach ein großes
spielzeug geil aus das einfach aus einem
traum gewesen immer so lamborghini mal
zu fahren als mit situation zu haben
hätte ich mir eigentlich hätte ich nie
gedacht dass ich mir das mal ermöglichen
kann ja ja und ja es macht einfach spaß
ist cool und auch mal selber so eine
belohnung so weist das selber immer so
sagt das ist also nicht dafür machst du
das also ich arbeite ja nicht so dass
ich mir so was sie kaufen kann oder so
materialscience aber das zeigt die immer
so ein bisschen ok krass so das will ich
immer wieder auf den boden und zeigt dir
selber stolz auf dich und mit dem was du
gerade das suche also
recht herzlichen glückwunsch dazu muss
man sagen also ja genau voraus ich sagte
ja wir machen die fahrschule zu
fahrschule ja gar nicht wirklich richtig
geil finde ich finde ich bevor ich dich
jetzt auch heute so zum ersten wirklich
kennen lernt hat dass wir zu zweit mal
miteinander unterwegs bin habe ich auch
schon ein volk viele freunde von mir
auch mit sachen gesehen ja krass saves
christ heran das ist ein geiles gefühl
wie geil ist das wenn du dich stadt
läuft es ist okay du hast so heftig weil
wenn du überlegst dieser ganzen kroner
zeit wo halt so lockdown und alles war
da hast du es da ging es ja bei uns so
richtig los da erst mal aber du hattest
nie so die möglichkeit in der stadt oder
draußen die leute zu sehen
du weißt schon okay viele leute kaufen
die sachen und bar oder aber du siehst
die leute nicht wenn du wenn halt
lockdown löste waren ja das erste mal
wirklich dann offenbar und dann halten
die stadt gehst oder so einsetzen dass
wir also ab und zu gehe ich mal
spazieren am rhein oder so lammerding
und seite voll viele leute mit deinen
sachen unseren text award klassiker ist
schon ist schon heftig sowieso
also schon übertrieben geiles gefühl
fischer was ich würde sogar schon sagen
was das mit eines der geilsten gefühle
so also du du siehst einfach leute
feiern deine sachen leute tragen damit
sachen wo und deine designs wurde und
ganz genau weiß er da und da ist sagt
darauf dass nachts zwei uhren habt habt
ihr das und das gemacht was ich meine
und dem wo die gearbeitet und ist schon
ist schon heftig richtig geil digger
haben freilich des todes so dass einfach
wenn die leute wenn man selbst so sich
so etwas aufgebaut hat und man sieht
okay es funktioniert das ist das ist das
geilste rückt wissen das so wenn du halt
das ganze projekt von 0 halt aufbaus 0
begleitet und dann auch du weißt du dass
schweiß blut weißt du diese ganzen
diesen ganzen diese ganzen
ein ganzes herz da reinstecken so und
dann diese ganzen mit allen ups und
downs und alles drum und dran wo das
schon reicht schon heftig wenn du dann
direkt die ist okay irgendwann mal auch
vielleicht vielleicht
erst nach drei jahren oder so ist aber
dieser moment wo du merkst okay das
ganze funktioniert das ganze lohnt sich
um diese arbeit hat sich gelohnt ich
schon ist schon heftig oder an der
schnellbus aufstocken
ok ich hab' perfekt sind gerne hier muss
ich hier nicht erklären ne okay ist ganz
einfach gut ich probier's einfach mal
von selbst
genau jetzt hier
ganz links einstelle drive ist muss hier
schaltwippe noch herunterschalten sport
und corsa ein bisschen was waren noch
banken aber ist schon krank was das auto
alles kann das ist wirklich krank leute
kommen wir hier jetzt einmal den anime
scheiter die seele vom lambo geschrei
wird lauter
aber im sport ja jetzt direkt auf corsa
jetzt gibt es
das schon dass pharma es gibt man gas
jetzt aber wieder runter wieder runter
dass die vordenker weiß das ist das
erste das ab
das heißt dass ich da plötzlich der
brust
da ist der 1 das sommergewitter ist das
aggressiv leute jetzt einen teil geld
aus dem lambo fahren dazu tanken guck
mal dieser tankdeckel das ist doch
einfach wenn nena ristic carbon
jetzt sehen wir wie er ist kann man hier
mit dem relativ leeren tank das machen
wir einmal voll freudiger
aktion hörte dass der warenwert 183 der
liter leute damals
74 liter rein natürliche man den letzten
kopfschütteln
kranken zu sagen wir ja auch interessant
leute wenn ihr mal hier guckt hier sehen
wir zum beispiel die originalfarbe noch
das schwarze das war der der originalton
und hier guck mal hier sogar das finde
ich sogar diese details sind kein paar
schlappe alcantara hier die abdeckung
alcantara das einfach sexy wirklich sexy
cora diese leuchten die sich hieraus
ziehen ist wirklich schon sehr schön
sehr schön muss ich sagen ja dann lasst
heute das rein dies ist aber die
sitzwangen wir die sich zu ziehen das
ist ein richtig geiles
okay jetzt geht's los
[Musik]
geschickt er
krank war und wir sehen 600 kilometer
reichweite mit 80 liter das ist gut so
ja ich finde dafür seien riesa ist oder
so wenn du auf der autobahn bis zum
entspannt fans
bis 16
[Musik]
diese gangwechsel auch sollte das ist so
in your face schon bald in your face
ticker das muss musik und tanz das denn
das muss auch ein
doppelkupplungsgetriebe sein ich hab's
gar nicht kommen muss ist das schadet so
schnell also wenn es ein wandel ist
wundert einmal anima auf cocoa der ist
so gibt der ja der ist so laut auf corsa
direkt
[Musik]
das merken
wir dass unser buch
junge ist das geisteskrank vor was ein
schub alter junge also ich mache es ihr
bruder habe das bild ja wirklich schon
so schnelle autos gefahren aber das ist
auf jeden fall von der power herr mit
der lounge ganz oben mit dabei also
leute die jetzt nach einem sehr
emotionalen tag den wir langsam wieder
zurück nach köln im stau im fernverkehr
er ist wirklich aus akkus an dich hab
mir sehr viel spaß gemacht heute sind
das eine sehr gute einstellung und
helfer auto danke dir leute passt
gemacht ja ich habe jetzt verlinkt
erstinstanzlich auf jeden fall rein zu
folgen oder jetzt auch mal verlinkt und
wir kommen ja zur bewertung und die
bewertung beginnt natürlich wie immer
wird es bereits heute mit dem aussehen
der urus sieht richtig sexy aus naila
bulliger auftritte zerklüftete front
vorne sehr schönes heck auch
wunderschöne details rund um das auto
herum dann muss das nur neun von zehn
gehen beschleunigung fühlt sich absolut
brachial an ist auf dem papier am ende
auch wegen 2,2 tonnen dann doch nicht so
groß also nicht dass es kratzer weiß
nicht übertrieben krass mit 3,6 sekunden
von oder fühlt sich aber mehr an wie 2,8
aber die werte auf papier zählen am ende
des wegen acht von zehn was die cool das
angeht ist das auto meiner meinung nach
über jeden zweifel erhaben das ist ja
quasi vergriffen ist über den stahl
rolex modellen heutzutage oder bei
einigen patek philippe das tut die nur
über liste war auch bekommst auf dem
graumarkt quasi was gibt es einen
besseren beweis dafür dass ein auto sehr
begehrt und coole die kombination der
marke lamborghini mit zum richtigen
schlachtschiff von suv finde ich einfach
richtig geil cooles 10c der spaß komme
damit auf 27 von 30 punkten und platz
sechs übrigens ich wollte natürlich auch
nochmal den sound hier nicht unerwähnt
lassen der auch absolut bestialisch ist
zumindest im corsa oder die
praktikabilität ist gut ich meine klar
ist ist ein suv coupé das sind sich
nicht ganz so praktisch wie die
klassischen suv ist die bisschen ruhe
bauen hinten aber das auto ist wirklich
praktisch man kann die hintere sitzreihe
umlegen und dann kann man wirklich
wirklich eine ganze menge rein laden
schön öffnen der heckklappe klar
ladekante bisschen hoch aber wenn du es
ist ein top auto auch in der praktischen
hinsicht acht von zehn preis leisten
natürlich jetzt schwierig beim auto was
über zwei weit über 200.000 euro liste
kostet aber lasst uns nicht mal so sagen
wenn ihr die das auto zum listenpreis
bekommt dann habt ihr eigentlich sofort
einen gewinn gemacht was vollkommen
absurd ist weil wir wissen selbst am
besten wenn ihr ein auto kauft der vaart
vom hochbauamt 10 15 fällt sogar 20% weg
und hier ist es einfach mal andersrum
meiner meinung nach reicht das aus der
sieben von zehn und jetzt kommen wir zu
dem punkt der mich am meisten geschockt
hat der lamborghini urus kann wirklich
unfassbar komfortabel sitzbelüftung
massagesitze luftfahrwerk und dazu die
fähigkeit wenn man es möchte einen
wirklich sehr sehr sehr zivilen wagen zu
haben zumindest vom klang ja ich meine
er sieht immer so aus wie er aussieht
aber der kann wirklich so leise dass man
es gar nicht das reicht für mich
insgesamt aus um hier acht von zehn zu
geben alltags wertungen damit 23 von 30
gleichbedeutend mit platz vier von 20
und das für einen lamborghini
unfassbar und alle die fit sind wissen
was jetzt schon kommt wir kommen
insgesamt auf 50 von 60 punkten und
damit einen unbestrittenen platz eins
geisteskrank das auto elias wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sympathischer typ
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
und bis zur nächsten woche macht gut